well it's still a little warm out but we
are pretending it's fall over here and
it is officially fall so it's time to
get ready for the season thanks to
TaylorMade Productions the sponsors of
today's segment here with some fall
must-haves as entertaining expert and
one of my good friends Paula thank you
for being here thank you for having me
you ready for fall I am so ready a lot
to talk about this table looks great so
let's get right to it we're talking
fashion first yes you need a wardrobe
refresh and frying Co is an iconic
American brand it's got some great
craftsmanship and they've teamed up with
JCPenney to launch this new line Western
inspired at an accessible price point so
everything from jackets to boots to
leather goods to accessories they got
you covered and it's a great price point
go to jcpenney.com for more information
about fry and Co I love it well soon
enough at least be in the 80s so we can
wear some jean jackets all right moving
on are these cocktails do we need fall
Cocktails so we have some bowls ready to
enjoy Cocktails so what these are these
are already made craft cocktails with
100 natural flavors and no preservatives
and what you do is you just shake it up
I love this pour it in over ice and
you're good to go so you have the tube
that has two drinks these have four
drinks we have a red light Negroni an
old-fashioned an espresso martini and a
Blue Margarita and you can pick these up
at least liquor.com so if you're doing
like tailgating anything like that throw
them in your bag and voila you have the
cocktails made easy look you're not
lying this is blue this looks delicious
delicious look at this super easy you're
a master mixologist all right well
cheers to that let's keep going down the
line this looks amazing we need some
food now that we have drinks so we have
some items from Smart and Final it is a
Family Foods month and so families are
getting together having meals and smart
and final is taking the guessing work
out of that so it is one trip and that's
it we have some egg bites we have some
pizza bites we have some fresh fruit and
they have the big Club sizes but without
a membership fee and if you want all
this delivered you go to
smartandfinal.com one click and that's
it and they even have fresh herbs for
family meal night and everything like
that what do you think this is great
Paul you're bringing me pizzas and
Cocktails I mean this is why we're
friends and now we have more cocktails
what do we have over here we have some
parts tequila so this is the world's
highest rated tequila it's 100 blue
Weber Agave it's absolutely delicious we
have an Anejo we have a Reposado and a
Blanco the inejo it's fall why not try
an old-fashioned with some of the inejos
try something a little bit different
exactly exactly and they're absolutely
delicious and you can get these at Lee's
Liquor is this the same thing this is
different this is some dessert cocktails
with Mozart Chocolate liqueurs so these
are all natural ingredients chocolate
from Belgium we have a pumpkin spice
chocolate liqueur for that you know
spiked pumpkin spice latte we have a
coffee one we have a chocolate one
there's a vegan one I mean there's
something for everyone because we're
doing a false Soiree you could perhaps
shop for your husband for the one year
anniversary with a nice little Western
jacket and voila follow us all and hey
we can have a party with some coffee
tails and some mini pizzas some fresh
herbs a little bit of everything and
look at this yeah this is our favorite
thing it's already like wow how fun is
that and I'm a sucker for anything
pumpkin spice so thank you so much for
breaking everything down for us cheers
this is the old-fashioned you know let's
get it done we're having fun thank you
so much for being here it's always so
much fun and time to do our fall
shopping all right well it